the revenue beat is modest but
nevertheless a revenue beam will have to
go a full year compensation bradon's
36.8 percent full your compensation
ratio this is by far the clearest
headlines Thank you Thank You Lloyd
Blankfein I appreciate you for making my
Friday easier Goldman Sachs
fourth-quarter earnings per share four
dollars and thirty eight times that is
slightly better than consensus estimates
for four dollars and thirty six cents
time we have seen disappointment and
matches from nearly all the big banks on
Wall Street this is a very different
story than what we saw from JPMorgan
obviously the big concern was we were
going to see this enormous slow down and
trading and maybe even some more costs
but it looks like Goldman Sachs has
really bucked the trend in particular
without looking through the details I
would bet a lot of this strength is
coming out of their IPO and their
advisory business yeah it's a nice bead
on this number of people headlining that
Brad Hintz with NYU informally the San
for bursting the fick the fixed income
currency commodity we forget how big
Goldman is fifteen point two billion is
a very nice number what is it signal
that the others struggle and that
Goldman pure training does a beat I mean
does that simply mean there are more
efficient more focused and more risk
oriented than the other banks in terms
of fixed income remember they have a
large commodities business will have to
hear the commentary of course we oak did
they did they do well in terms of that
in terms of the mixes the mixes of the
businesses and relative the banks
Goldman's going to be somewhat smaller
and foreign exchange the banks are going
to be larger you're sitting at NYU next
of the legendary Roy Smith who's pretty
good and had a storied history at
Goldman Sachs what professor Smith
recognized today's Goldman Sachs well
Goldman Sachs is is clearly much more of
a trading house than it was when when
Roy was there what we're seeing now
those we're seeing a shift back in the
other direction right you know the
fixity it is the investment banking
businesses that are doing soul so well
to that point Ellen petrikov how do you
dovetail with golden insects and venture
capital a very little are they a
competitor they help you or they're your
frenemy they're uh I call my friend
a friend of me but I go ahead and
Goldman Sachs has a private equity
investing group and that private equity
investing group which i'm not sure as
off the balance she I think it made me
the client spends on the moon I don't
know Olivia what else you said Frank
they could they they're not allowed to
do it so they are player as is fidelity
and and Wellington and t rowe price
they're all in those big deals which
you're reading about in the paper that
at the billion to be almost pension they
will don't do so they want to put big
blocks of money yeah okay the Libya what
else do you see jumps out of me is the
fourth quarter return on equity 11.1
percent that is that is a pickup in roee
puts its second behind wells fargo which
is movable bank but i mean that's pretty
interesting that's sort of the similar
IRR that you're looking at we're great
more than that I hope and then Brad
Hintz here's a headline it's important
total staff increased three percent
during 2014 everybody's talking about
cost-cutting but you still need the
brains to make the place go well that's
very true recognize the Goldman has been
a leader in terms of moving its high
cost operations out of New to Utah so
lower lows locations right so you're
seeing Dallas you're seeing you tall
you're seeing India right because this
you know that's a way of bringing your
expenses down your head count isn't
changing okay Brad Hintz with us the
headline you're certainly Goldman doing
a bit better than the others